[Music]
have we had anything to drink today no
no our a just left us he's actually like
in route huh our axe
boyfriend okay your
axe kind of so how much have we had to
drink today nothing nothing so why are
we speeding I'm doing 45 and you're
coming up on me like I'm standing still
in a 35 M hour Zone you have your idea
on you
of course I do do you want my passport
or which one do you
want no
attitude no I'm being honest you want to
call Katie you want me to call Kevin or
Tammy
413 no excuse me pardon me I'm calling
Diane Quinn actually I don't care who
you're calling come
on don't touch my phone I'm I'm going to
y yank it out I'm yank you out if you
don't come out on your
own don't give
me let's go record him record him I got
it decide she's refusing to come out not
refusing
anything no I want to smoke cigarette
I'm fine I'm actually all put the
cigarette down can I please no put the
cigarette
down please you need to listen to him
let's go please all right watch out
please here we're going to close the
door listen man we're going over here
all right go with that I'm going to stay
here come on let's go come
on fucking Chicago except Chicago get
shot actually cops getop which
sucks all right so have we had anything
to drink today no no so why are you
slurring why am I slurring because our
my boyfriend actually jumped out of the
car about 20 mil back so if I'm a little
bit upset and I'm also in school for
nursing a child at the time and my a
took three of my kids to
Chicago Florida
deal good for
you go ahead you can actually verify all
that you want help no I'm aware no okay
good
passport on way fory cards actually in
my
uh boyfriend never jumps out of the car
might all right do May favor take your
hat off for
me all right come on up over here so
we're out of the road all right
so like I told you my walk uh when I
drove up you drove up on me like I was
standing
still talking to you inside the car you
got slur speech I don't have slur speech
you have to understand everything that
I've been through
and three of my kids are in Chicago
because my ex took them and we have
therapy we actually have okay well I'm
not I'm not here for that you know have
we anything to drink no worries no
worries that's not youring problem nope
it's not so do me a favor go ahead and
put your hands at your side do you want
me to do a freaking back flip I'll do
that for you all right so with your eyes
and eyes only what you can do is you're
going to keep an eye on this blue light
all right so hands at your sides it's
not even
happen so how much have we had to drink
tonight nothing thing I actually have
actually I have my prescription with my
contact if you want to go check it
out cuz that's actually a written
doctor's note so if you want to sit
there we can play that game all right so
where are we coming
from where am I coming from my aunt's
house in K she's a doctor okay all right
so we're going to go ahead and play this
game all right so based on your driving
pattern well not really I didn't really
have driving pattern but
B I don't care about your boyfriend
right now B thir speech I'm thinking
you're under the influence of good I
think you're under the influence of
alcohol do you want to participate in uh
F sobriety exercises no I don't have to
sorry Chicago me better so she is the
registered owner not valid she 's tag
and a um business purposes only so she's
coming from her aunt's house she's not
in
business okay can you just cannot this
is you wanted to play this game so let's
play how much have we had to drink
tonight nothing do you want to take care
of people that are robbing
people people that are driving drunk on
my roads shooting up houses out here
robbing people you want to take care of
those people I'm taking care of people
that are driving uh driving crazy right
now you're fing making up your own story
at this point okay so do you want to
participate in F soety
exercises you for a lighter I would have
cooperated with you you have no idea
what the hell we okay I'm not here for
what's going on last 25 minutes you want
to sit there and say I've been drinking
I will sit there and do handstand I
don't care about the handstand do you
want to do do you want to do fuel
sobriety exercises yes or I can do a f
sobriety that you can't even pass okay
so do you want to do do you want to do a
f sobriety exercises yes or no what do
you want me to do it's a yes or no
answer what do you want me to do yes or
no answer answer my question no you
answer mine that's not how this game
works no I'm sir that's not how it works
yes that is exactly how this works it's
a yes or no answer do you wish to
participate in F sobriety exercises I
want to call my grandpa so yes or no yes
or no do you want do you want me to do a
backr I'm sorry if someone's drunk can
they do that probably not right so yes
or no call my grandpa right now so yes
yes or
no
please thank you yes or no no don't
worry someone's about to show
up all right eron so just based off your
uh your you're coming up on me you know
like I was standing still your slur
speech I believe you're under uh under
the influence of alcohol not even slur
speech okay it's a lot of other shit
going on your ex was an axe like three
of my kids are in Chicago all right so
just like we did before what you going
do is you're going to stand with your
feet together your hands at your
sides all right so with your right index
finger it's going to be this finger
right here you're going to touch the top
of this
light touch the top of the light all
right put your hand back down okay the
feet together your hands at your sides
you're going to follow this light that
you just touched with your index finger
without moving your head you
understand
all right put your hand back
down all right so with your eyes and
Rise only do not move your head follow
this light with your eyes and eyes only
do you want your
understand keep your head
still
I have too much going through my
mind hands at your feet together and
hands at your sides
yeah me to do a back flip I can do
that do you want stand right there just
like I told you with the left foot on
the line your right foot in front yeah
but you know what your tests don't even
measure so do not start until I tell you
what do you
understand all
right are you ready for me to
begin okay so right back to where you
were with your left foot on the line
your right fo the front of it when I
tell you you're going to take nine he to
toe steps you're going to go go all the
way down you're going to count up to
nine when you get down to your ninth
step you're going to going to take your
lead
foot can you do me a favor just
listening what you
want why don't you actually show me what
you want and I will do that come here I
got another I got an easier one for
you
know I'm not resisting I'm not resisting
Ro I told you to show me what you want
4113 feel on rest for
Dy do you have any guns knives hand
grenades explosives and S devices on you
no I got a block in my
fucking there you have a gun in the seat
no sir you just said you did I said I
got a block in my safe you're welcome
actually from
[Music]
Sergeant ni
white yeah that's
was do you have any drugs on you
nope all right so this is what I'm going
to tell you if you have any drugs or any
illegal substances on you but when we
get to where we're going if you have
anything it's going to be an
introduction of Contraband do you
understand honestly this
I'm leaving this house